>> DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING ANTSY
FOR AN ANSWER FROM BIDEN ON HIS
2024 PLANS.
LAST NIGHT'S INTERVIEW DIDN'T
CLEAR ANY OF THAT UP.
>> IF I WERE TO SAY TO YOU, I'M
RUNNING AGAIN, ALL OF A SUDDEN A
WHOLE RANGE OF THINGS COME IN TO
PLAY THAT I HAVE REQUIREMENTS
HAVE TO CHANGE AND MOVE AND DO.
>> IN TERMS OF ELECTION LAWS?
>> IN TERMS OF ELECTION LAWS.
IT'S MUCH TOO EARLY TO MAKE THAT
KIND OF DECISION.
MY INTENTION, AS I SAID TO BEGIN
WITH, IS THAT I WOULD RUN AGAIN,
BUT IT'S JUST AN INTENTION.
IS IT A FIRM DECISION THAT I RUN
AGAIN?
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
BIDEN'S ANSWER GIVING A HOARD OF
HUNGRY DEMOCRATS AT BAY.
GAVIN NEWSOM IS CHAMPING AT THE
BIT.
IN A NEW REPORT, HE'S
UNEQUIVOCALLY RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024 IF BIDEN
DOESN'T, WITH A FUNDRAISER
SAYING NO IFS, ANDS OR BUTS.
HMM, JESSICA.
I'M NOT SURE I CAN TAKE THAT
STRONG LANGUAGE.
DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO
MATTER IF GAVIN NEWSOM IF BIDEN
RUNS OR NOT?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE WILL
CHALLENGE HIM.
CERTAINLY NO ONE WHO WANTS TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CAREER IN
DEMOCRATIC POLITICS.
THERE COULD BE SOME LOONEY-TYPE
PERSON THAT DOES IT.
GAVIN NEWSOM PLAYS BY THE RULES.
HE WANTS TO CONTINUE OBVIOUSLY
BEING THE GOVERNOR, YOU KNOW, IF
BIDEN DOESN'T STEP ASIDE.
I REALLY WISH THE PRESIDENT,
THOUGH, HAD BEEN AS CLEAR AS HE
HAD BEEN IN OTHER INTERVIEWS,
WHERE HE SAID, I AM RUNNING
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
NOW IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO PICK
YOUR FAVORITE WARRIOR.
I'M GOING TO BE A KAMALA PERSON.
I'M GOING TO BE A PETE PERSON.
AMY KLOBUCHAR.
>> JESSE BROUGHT UP KAMALA.
DO YOU THINK THE REASON THERE'S
NOT ANSWERING THE QUESTION
BECAUSE SHE'S A EMBARRASSMENT?
>> NO.
IT'S NOT UP TO BIDEN WHETHER HE
RUNS AGAIN.
I HAVE A FEELING SOMEONE WILL
TELL HIM.
HE COULD ANNOUNCE HE'S RUNNING
FOR RE-ELECTION, AND THE WHITE
HOUSE HAVE TO WALK IT BACK.
THE AMERICAN POLICY ON THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN IS HE WILL NOT BE
RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION.
IMAGINE TREATING A WOMAN THIS
WAY.
MY INTENTION IS TO MARRY YOU,
BUT IT'S JUST AN INTENTION.
IS IT A FIRM DECISION?
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR.
IT ACTUALLY IS, BECAUSE IT'S THE
MOST UNIFYING HE'S EVER BEEN.
THE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
HEARING THAT ARE, LIKE, ALL
RIGHT, THAT'S THE WAY TO GO.
REPUBLICANS NOT MAKING THIS A
STORY.
IT'S THE LIBERAL MEDIA ASKING
JOE BIDEN THIS QUESTION OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
IT'S THE LIBERAL MEDIA ASKING
OTHER DEMOCRATS, IF HE RUNS
AGAIN, ARE YOU GOING TO SUPPORT
HIM?
THIS ISN'T OUR ISSUE.
THEY'VE BEEN WANTING HIM FOR OUT
FOR A LONG TIME.
HE WAS YOUTHFUL BEAT TRUMP.
HE'S LIKE A TUXEDO.
YOU WEAR IT ON SPECIAL
OCCASIONS, BUT EVERY DAY YOU
LOOK RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
HE'S NOT GOING TO RUN.
YOU'LL HAVE GAVIN NEWSOM, BERNIE
SANDERS, PETE BUTTIGIEG AND --
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, JUDGE?
>> MY FAVORITE PART OF THIS, MY
INTENTION IS, BUT IS THAT A FIRM
POSITION, NO.
MY SECOND FAVORITE LINE, DO YOU
HAVE THE MENTAL ACUITY TO DO
THIS AGAIN?
HE SAYS, YOU WATCH.
KEEP MY SCHEDULE.
HIS SCHEDULE?
HE'S BEEN ON VACATION IN
DELAWARE FOR 155 DAYS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, HE SAYS,
IT'S A MATTER OF, YOU KNOW THE
OLD EXPRESSION, THE PROOF OF THE
PUDDING IS IN THE EATING.
NO, I DON'T KNOW THAT
EXPRESSION.
HE KEEPS PUTTING HIS FOOT IN HIS
MOUTH THIS.
GUY IS NOT TOTAL WILL YOU WITH
IT.
YOU AGREE WITH JESSE.
I THINK SOMEBODY ELSE IS MAKING
THE DECISION.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A MISTAKE
FOR HIM TO RUN AGAIN.
>> DANA?
>> I THINK IT MAY BE MORE
PRACTICAL WHY HE MADE THAT
ANSWER.
ONE IS THERE ARE WEIRD FEDERAL
ELECTION LAWS, THAT IF YOU
DECLARE YOU'RE RUNNING, ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU HAVE TO START
COUNTING THE MONEY YOU GET FOR
YOUR GENERAL ELECTION VERSUS
WHAT YOU CAN PAY FOR YOUR
PRIMARY, AND IT GETS A LITTLE
COMPLICATED.
I IMAGINE ALSO THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ANOTHER
ONE OF THOSE GRAND, YOU KNOW,
EVENTS LIKE IN PHILADELPHIA THEY
HOPEFULLY WOULD NOT DO AS BADLY
AS THE LAST SPEECH WHERE THEY
ADVANCED IT DIFFERENTLY.
WHEN HE ANNOUNCES HE'S RUNNING
AGAIN, IF HE DOES, THEY WANT IT
TO BE A BIG DEAL, NOT SOMETHING
YOU SAY ON "60 MINUTES" WHILE
EVERYBODY ELSE IS WATCHING
FOOTBALL.
>> THEY WANT TO CURE RATE IT,
MAKE IT SPECIAL.
THAT MAKES SENSE.